Ванья із однодумцями святкують перемогу:
Німеччина зробила вирішальний крок
до узаконення "третьої статі".
В усіх людей є якась ідентичність,
в якій вони себе бачать або могли б себе описати.
Але якщо у мене виникає почуття, що для того,
ким я є, навіть не існує слів, або простору,
або прикладів для наслідування...
Це дуже ускладнило мені дитинство і дорослішання
З 2013 року в Німеччині не обов'язково вказувати
стать дитини у свідоцтві про народження.
Ваньє через суд вдалося добитися, щоб особи
з міжстатевою приналежністю в графі "стать"
змогли обирати - "різний" або "інший".
Конституційний суд Німеччини підтвердив,
що бінарність порушує права деяких людей.
А цього допускати не можна,
навіть якщо мова йде про невелику групу людей.
Потрібно поважати права як великих, так
і маленьких груп населення."
Таких людей, як Ванья, у Німеччині, за приблизними
оцінками, від 100 до 160 тисяч осіб.
Через хромосомні порушення у Ваньї, наприклад,
тільки хромосома X - в їхніх гормонах,
статевих залозах і геніталіях виражені ознаки як жіночої,
так і чоловічої статі.
Щорічно лише у Німеччині народжується
від 300 до 500 таких дітей.
Довгий час німецькі лікарі переконували
батьків одразу вирішити, якої статі буде їхня дитина.
Їй робили операцію, щоб вона відповідала
загальноприйнятим нормам.
Така практика існує і досі.
Громадські організації вважають таке втручання
порушенням прав людини.
Це за принципом: іншого вибору немає.
А дитині потім все життя бути з цим тілом і цією статтю.
І ймовірність того, що батьки ухвалили
правильне рішення - 50 на 50.
Все може бути добре, але може і не бути.
Тож рішення Конституційного суду ФРН - лише перший крок.
В організації вважають, що в німецьке
законодавство потрібно внести багато змін.
Перш за все, на законодавчому рівні захистити дітей
з міжстатевою приналежністю
від операцій на статевих органах.
Виникають і інші запитання: чи зможуть такі люди
перетнути кордон, якщо у них в закордонному паспорті
в графі "стать" буде стояти "інший"?
Або як особами з міжстатевою приналежністю
укладати законні шлюби?
На ці та багато інших запитань ще належить знайти
відповіді німецькому суспільству.